The combination of collaborative editing and inline discussion...
...makes Wave a powerful platform for document creation.
I'll show you that by opening a design doc we wrote on our team.
I'll make a little more room...
...and you can see this has rich fonts,...
...it has diagrams, it has inline discussion.
The best way to view Wave when it's picked up a certain amount of structure...
...is using a feature we built called, Playback.
Playback tells you how the Wave built up.
Steven, our trusted server guy wrote a draft.
He added a bunch of people.
Lars, the manager said, "It's a good start but needs more."
Steven added more.
I made some edits and so on.
I can pick up the slider and move to any part of the Wave.
Playback is a powerful way to investigate and manipulate the history of a Wave.